welcome back everyone this is part two
in our series on methods and metrics in
part one I introduced some really high
level overarching themes around methods
and metrics we're now going to do a deep
technical dive on classifier metrics
because I imagine many of you will be
dealing with classifiers for your final
project even though this is a deep
technical dive I'd like to keep our eyes
on those high level themes
in fact let's start there with an
overview of thinking about this
carrying over a lesson from the first
screencast I would emphasize that
different evaluation metrics encode
different values and that means that
choosing a metric is a crucial aspect of
your experimental work you need to think
about your hypotheses and your data and
your models and how all of those come
together to inform good choices around
metrics even if you are fitting
something as seemingly simple as a
classifier
you should feel free to motivate new
metrics and specific uses of existing
metrics depending on what your goals are
that's something that I emphasized in
part one of this series that we should
really be thinking about how our metrics
align with the things that we're
actually trying to do
for established tasks I grant that there
will usually be pressure to use specific
metrics the ones that are in the
leaderboards are in the prior literature
but you should feel empowered to push
back if you feel that's the right thing
to do after all areas of research can
stagnate due to poor metrics so we all
have to be vigilant and push back if we
think that a metric is just leading us
astray
in that Spirit let's start with
confusion matrices the basis for many
calculations in this area as a running
example I'm going to use a ternary
sentiment problem I'll have the gold
labels across the rows and predictions
going down the columns and so this
confusion Matrix is saying for example
that there were 15 cases that were gold
positive and that the system predicted
as positive whereas there are a hundred
cases that were gold positive and the
system predicted neutral
in the spirit of taking nothing for
granted let me emphasize for you that a
threshold was likely imposed for these
categorical predictions coming from the
model especially if you have a
probabilistic classifier what you got
out was a probability distribution over
the three classes in this case and you
applied some decision rule to figure out
which one would count as the actual
prediction so obviously different
decision rules will give you very
different tables of results and so in
the background you should have in mind
that that is an ingredient here and in
fact at the end of the slideshow I'll
suggest a metric that allows you to pull
back from that assumption
another thing that's worth keeping track
of is the support that is the number of
cases that for the gold data fall into
each one of the categories here you can
see that it is highly imbalanced and you
should have in mind that that will be an
important factor in choosing a good
metric
let's begin with accuracy accuracy is
the correct predictions divided by the
total number of examples given a
confusion table like this that means
that we sum up all the diagonal elements
and divide that by the sum of all the
elements in the table that's accuracy
the balance for accuracy are zero and
one with zero the worst and one the best
the value encoded in accuracy is just in
the simplest terms how often is the
system correct
that actually relates to two weaknesses
first there is no per class metric we
have to do this over the entire table
second we have a complete failure to
control for class size think about that
value encoded how often is the system
correct that is insensitive to the
different classes that you have in your
system and the way it makes predictions
for those classes it is just looking at
the raw number of times that you made
the right guess
and actually our table is a good
illustration of how this can be
problematic essentially all of the true
cases are neutral and essentially all of
the predictions are neutral and as a
result it hardly matters what you do for
this system in terms of positive and
negative because accuracy will be
totally dominated by performance on that
neutral category that could be good it's
giving us a picture of how your system
performs on the most frequent case and
it will reflect the value that I've
suggested here but it might be directly
at odds with our goals of really doing
well on even the smallest categories
suppose that you do have a goal of doing
well even on the small categories I'm
going to offer you some metrics for that
but one thing you should keep in mind
again is that if you are using a cross
entropy loss you are implicitly
optimizing your model for accuracy
because accuracy is inversely
proportional to the negative log loss
that is the cross entropy loss so you
might set goals for yourself that are
like good macro F1 that's a metric I'll
introduce in a second but keep in mind
that your system is actually oriented
toward accuracy and that will have
consequences for example optimization
processes tend to favor the largest
classes and this is a picture of why
that happens for classifiers
one other technical note that I wanted
to make the cross entropy loss is
actually a special case of the KL
Divergence loss and that's kind of
accuracy for soft labels where you have
a full probability distribution over the
classes
the reason we often simplify this away
is that typically for classifiers we
have a one hot Vector there's exactly
one label Dimension that is true and
that means that for all other classes
the false ones this ends up being a
total of zero and that means we can
simplify it down to the negative log of
the true class and that's how you get
back to these standard formulations but
this is the general formulation and you
can in principle learn from
distributions over the labels that you
have and that will be fundamentally the
same kind of operation with the same
inbuilt biases
but we do want to move away from raw
accuracy and the first step to doing
that is precision
the Precision for a class K is the
correct predictions for K divided by the
sum of all guesses for K so we're going
to kind of operate column wise here and
here I've shown you the calculation for
precision for the positive class and we
can do similar calculations for the
negative and neutral classes
the bounds of precision are zero and one
with zero the worst and one the best
with a small caveat that Precision is
undefined for cases where you would need
to divide by zero so we just map those
to zero typically and sometimes if
you're using scikit you see lots of
warnings about metrics when you
encounter this case
the value encoded is penalizing
incorrect guesses and that leads
directly to the weakness you can achieve
High Precision for a class K simply by
rarely guessing k
if you just make sure you're very
cautious about this class you will get
high Precision in all likelihood but
that's not necessarily the full set of
values we want to encode
so typically we balance that with recall
the recall for class K is the correct
predictions for K divided by the sum of
all true members of K so here we're
going to operate row wise and I've given
you the sample calculation for the
positive class
the bounds are zero and one with zero
the worst and one the best the value
encoded is that we're going to penalize
missed true cases so it is a kind of
dual of precision
and that encodes its weakness as well we
can achieve High recall for K simply by
always guessing K if I want to be sure I
don't miss any examples I'll just guess
constantly and increase my chances of
not having any misses and now you can
see very directly that we should balance
this against Precision which is imposing
the opposite value and that's the usual
motivation for f scores usually F's one
scores but we can in principle have this
weight beta which will control the
degree to which we favor precision and
recall and again no need to go on
autopilot there are scenarios where
Precision is important and scenarios
where recall is important and you could
use beta to align your metrics with
those high level values that you have
but by default it's one which is an even
balance and what we're doing is simply
the harmonic mean of precision and
recall
this can be a per class notion so I've
given the F1 scores along the rows for
each one of those classes
the bounds are zero and one with zero
the worst and one the best and this is
always going to be between precision and
recall as the harmonic mean of those two
the value encoded is something like this
how much do the predictions for class K
align with true instances of K with beta
controlling the weight placed on
precision and recall so it's kind of
like both precision and recall have been
baked into this notion of aligning with
the truth
the weaknesses there's no normalization
for the size of the data set
and it ignores all the values off the
row and column for K if I'm doing the F1
for the positive class I don't pay
attention to any of these other values
no matter how many examples there are in
those on off elements and so that's a
kind of structural bias that gets built
in here a kind of a place that these
metrics miss when you think per class
we can average F scores in multiple ways
I'm going to talk about three macro
averaging weighted averaging and micro
averaging
let's start with macro this is the most
dominant choice in the field and the
reason is that we as nlpers tend to care
about categories no matter how large or
small they are and if anything we often
care more about the small classes than
the large ones because they're
interesting or hard
the macro average is simply going to
average across them numerically so I
simply do the average of these three
numbers so it gives equal weight to all
three bounds are zero and one zero the
worst and one the best the value encoded
is as I said same as F scores plus the
assumption that all classes are equal
regardless of size or support
the weaknesses a classifier that does
well only on small classes might not do
well in the real world that's the kind
of duel of caring a lot about small
classes suppose you do obsess over
positive and negative in the scenario
and you do really well on them but at
the cost of neutral well in the real
world your system is encountering mostly
neutral cases if it if it's failing on
them it might look like a really bad
system
a classifier that does well only on
large classes might do poorly on small
but vital smaller classes right so this
is the case where you might really care
about those small classes even more than
you care about the large one and that's
not reflected in the macro average
because it simply takes them all as
equal weight
Ed average F scores is a straightforward
way to average where you simply take
into account the total support and so
it's a straight up weighted numerical
average of the three F1 scores
the bouncer zero and one zero the worst
one the best the value encoded is the
same as the F scores plus the assumption
that class size does in fact matter in
this case so this will be more like
accuracy the weakness of course is that
large classes will heavily dominate so
we're back to that same weakness that we
had for accuracy
the final way of averaging F scores is
called micro averaging what you do here
is take each one of the classes and form
its own binary confusion Matrix for that
class and then you add them together and
you get a single binary table
the properties for this are again bound
zero and one zero the worst and one the
best the value encoded is exactly the
same as accuracy if you focus on the yes
category in that final table that you
constructed it is exactly the same as
accuracy so the weakness are same as F
scores plus a score for yes and a score
for no which is kind of annoying because
what do you do with the no category you
have to focus on yes so there's no
single number but the yes one was just
accuracy after all and that as far as I
can tell is the only one that everyone
pays attention to so overall I feel like
at this point you could just ignore
micro average F scores you still see
them in the literature and in results
tables from scikit I believe but overall
it's basically macro average to abstract
away from class size or weighted average
to bring in the overall class size as an
element in the metric those are the two
that I would suggest going forward and
only for fully balanced problems should
you fall back to accuracy where class
size won't be an interfering Factor
finally I wanted to return to that
observation I made at the start that
it's kind of irksome that we need to
always impose a decision boundary we
have to do the same thing with precision
and recall we could think very
differently about this we could have for
example precision and recall curves that
would allow us to explore the full range
of possible ways that our system could
make predictions given a decision
boundary this offers much more
information about trade-offs between
these two pressures and could be make it
much easier for people to align system
choices with the underlying values that
they have for their system
so I know it's impractical to ask this
because the field is fairly focused on
single summary numbers but I think it
could be interesting to think about
Precision recall curves to get much more
information and then if we do need to
choose a single number average Precision
is a summary of this curve that again
avoids the decision about how we weight
precision and recall and brings in much
more information you'll recognize this
as analogous to the average Precision
calculation that we did in the context
of information retrieval where again it
offered a very nuanced lesson about how
systems we're doing